Can I use the hammer bulb on a program that calls for the spiral bulb?
So when you're using the true right lots of times it'll show a picture and then it'll even have some data
Use the double bubble or use the spiral bulb for this or use this
You can just ignore that
For the most part so any bulb program any plasma program that would be a program that you're using the bulb for
You can use any bulb. Now, it is true that certain bulbs will give off
You know more energy
No, like true. I've doesn't have the bubble the double bubble anymore
They have the tornado bulb tube which does have more gas in it
than
just the hammer tube
But I don't think you need to buy another tube
To is that going to make that much of a difference
um, you know now true right really only has
Those two and then they have the one that you stand up like on a table for more distance
When Mike had true right he had lots of different bulbs um and
You know he's big into selling different bulbs. I don't think it made enough difference to have all those different bulbs
The more I mean for a technical standpoint for a quantum physics standpoint the more gas you have on the tube that you're excited
The more treat the the more treatment that you're going to get
But again, there's a there's a there's a balance there and how you know how much more how much should I you know
What is it worth getting a different bulb or not um we are actually having
uh
Our own tornado bulbs made that are larger than true rice tornado bulbs
Um, we're calling them the magna magna magna bulb um, we haven't actually have it up on our store
But I don't I'm just getting two of them in this week
And I have one that's called for I don't think it's necessary. We're not gonna certainly be pushing it
Um, but we're calling it a daytime bulb because it will put out more energy than the um
than um
Then the hammer bulb well um, okay, there's some questions here
So you to answer that you could use the hammer bulb on any of the bulb programs